this morning on the dishes chefs
bringing exotic flavors to every meal of
the day born in India Anita Jason Ghani
got a degree in microbiology before
starting a small catering business that
led to work as a pastry chef and
eventually the opening of her own
restaurants including Houston's pond and
cherry serving breakfast lunch and
dinner the popular venue drew special
acclaim for its exotic baked goods and
two years ago a second Pondicherry
location opened right here in new york
also with an all-day menu of flavorful
Indian specialties chef Anita Jason
Ghani welcome to the dish thanks for
being here tell us about this fabulous
table okay I start with the carrots
these vegetables are my favorite those
are pickled carrots and Indian pickles
are the kind of because they make you
forget about American pickles like yeah
they are not cucumber and you know Bryan
there's much more to where the spices
let me have the potato cakes over there
there are potato and tapioca there are
more Astra inspired recipe delicious and
the fried chicken is I think the best
fried chicken in the world it is fried
chicken with the chickpea flour batter
and a lot of yogurt and masala marinades
is really tasty and the okra is just a
simple seared okra with fennel and a
chili powder and salt and a couple of
spices very simple and now to probably
your favorite part is a cookies let me
go back to the two sauces those are my
favorite so the the tamarind chutney
over there is like a tamarind jaggery
spice paste sauce and the cilantro
chutney is like the green sauce it goes
on everything and then the cookies here
are just chocolate chili cookies that we
made 12 years ago in my kitchen at
indica by accident and they became one
they kind of got onto the menu now they
are most popular cookie and the spirit
is called the golden is communal
freshness my daughter is delicious oh
yeah drink expert I would have to say
you grew up in India yeah as a child
moved to Canada I would imagine how did
you not get the culture shock in the
whole cooking experience I did I mean it
was it's like being
in a different planet when you compare
how food in India is compared to food in
Canada the time which was all you know
there was so much genetic engineering
and the food looks so different and food
in India looks so much more real which
at the time seemed like it was ugly you
know the food here was not real but it's
getting there now you went to study
microbiology I did so how did you make
this turn well I wanted to go get into
cooking but my parents were like we are
not going to cook
we have cooks in the house to do that
you will go learn something you know
something more serious so I I was kind
of forced into doing something else and
science came naturally to me is easy and
you open your first restaurant in deaky
indica indica indica I'm sorry and 2001
yes what was the goal with that
restaurant what did you take Indian food
to where it had never been you know it
was always at the time the restaurants
were like the same genre it was like
they were all cooking the same food they
were buffet lines and not there's
anything wrong with that but there was
so much more to Indian food than that
and I had like my creative brain was
like has always been on fire so there's
so much opportunity with Indian food
doesn't just have to be rice and curry
so I hear that when you walk in to
Pondicherry the restaurant that you
opened in Houston initially and now in
New York there's a tote bag for sale yes
keep calm and carry on
that stems from just how difficult a
period you were going through when you
open yes well not just that it's like
people's impression of Indian food is
just curry and there is so much more to
that and we just how we do a play on
words on that are you also when you open
that first restaurant you you wrote an
essay recently which you said you were
you were pretty tough in the kitchen
when you started because he thought you
were supposed to be yeah because that's
what I had seen and you know at the time
I was and I wasn't a trained chef so I
had to come up with my own style they're
like I don't like my style kinder
gentler yeah yeah yeah I mean it did
just I mean the end your mother and my
mom with kids and it just didn't feel
right
you have the baked lab also in
Pondicherry which it was called an open
all day creative experiment what does
that well we just take you know Indian
sweets are very small and you know fudge
like and the
goodbye don't love all of them and I
loved you know European pastries so I
wanted to kind of bring those into the
Indian world with the spices and the
magic that goes with that so awesome
well listen if as you sign this dish
it's on your name you have to ask you if
there are any three people because there
are three of us that you could have this
meal with past or present who would they
be
okay so I'm gonna say Neil Armstrong he
was just only just talked about him my
recipe for the stock paneer in an indica
maybe twelve years ago made it to NASA
and there it was those little - yeah is
that for you know outer space good food
so maybe you saw always Michelle or
Barack Obama I don't know this is a
great table
thank you we stephanida a ginseng jason
Gotti yes Jason Ghani thank you so much
and for more on Anita and the dish head
to our website at CBS this morning calm